[Music]
this is the story of the wilson family
and their fight against a tiny microbe
called brucella abortis
long an enemy of america's livestock
farmers
somehow driving the cows up in the
morning doesn't seem quite the chore it
used to be
when a boy has been promised his first
calf
a calf all his own to raise and feed and
groom for shows
likely as not there'd be powerful
shortage of blue ribbon over the country
if all the big plans a boy makes for his
first calf came out just the way he
thought they would
bud wilson there and lamb have made lots
of plans and they're waiting with their
patients for flossie to cooperate
of course big plans don't belong to
youngsters only grown-ups make plans too
their planning is usually just a little
better season by age
they know that lots of things can happen
to plans
take tom wilson there he's planning a
bigger and better dairy farm finer herd
plenty of space to grow his own feed
more buildings
good living
things he'll be proud to pass on to his
son
[Music]
but lots can happen to plans
there is an enemy
tiny brucella abortis
magnified thousands of times for you to
see it here
brucella abortis a pretty sounding name
for a murderer
working secretly and steadily in the
dark confines of the animal's body this
evil little microbe flies a trade that
has cost cattle growers millions of
dollars
it is the cause of brucellosis or bangs
disease
[Music]
this tiny vicious germ gives no warning
it attacks silently invisibly
kills and destroys
its favorite victim is an unborn calf
national and state governments are
cooperating in the battle against
brucellosis by providing information and
by paying farmers for part of the loss
when they send infected animals to
slaughter
scientists of the united states
department of agriculture know the
treachery of this enemy of cattle
growers
the battle against it has gone on for
years and especially of late has brought
good results
[Music]
in 1934 one cow out of every 10 in the
united states was infected
10 years later the proportion had
dropped to one cow in 20.
in some states the percentage is still
alarmingly high
the enemy does not die easily
in most infections the cows take this
germ in through feed that's been
contaminated
[Music]
here is its favorite breeding ground the
reproductive organs particularly of
young heifers in first or second
pregnancy
literally millions of these microbes
invade the region between the uterus and
the sac that holds the unborn calf
like thieves in the night they rob the
unborn animal of its food and oxygen
flourishing on their ill-gotten gain
they infect the entire region prowling
and plundering and finally murdering
the disease can spread rapidly from one
animal to another
it takes an enormous toll of calves
often leaves breeding animals sterile
and it attacks human beings in a form of
disease called undulate fever
[Music]
brucellosis is no respecter of animals
and no respecter of plans
not even the most exciting ones
like having a calf of your own to raise
[Music]
brucellosis has struck
suddenly and without warning
this is the first sign that aborted calf
[Music]
after the act of abortion the cow expels
an uncountable number of germs
and can infect any cow that licks her or
eats feed that she has contaminated
drama speaking
yes mr wilson
sounds like brucellosis
get that heifer away from the rest of
your herd and get rid of her calf
bury it or none of your other animals
can get to it
use plenty of lime in the pit so that
the dogs won't dig it up
and be uh
that's right
and be sure to spread lime and
disinfectant on the ground where you
find the calf
that's right
and when you're through disinfect all
tools and your shoes
i'll be right out
[Music]
the dead calf is a dangerous source of
infection
[Music]
bury it in quick line
and bury it immediately
[Music]
buckets forks and shovels contaminated
with brucello organisms may be as
dangerous in spreading infection as the
dead calf
[Music]
next step tom wilson finds out how far
the disease has spread through his herd
how many animals are already infected
that means testing every cow including
the one which lost her calf
there's always a slim chance that some
other reason caused the abortion but it
is very slim
brucellosis causes 85 of all cattle
abortions
scientists have devised the
agglutination test
and animals which show a positive
reaction to it are shipped off for
slaughter
there is no cure for brucellosis
although many a farmer has paid out good
sums of money for worthless so-called
remedies
[Music]
the veterinarian draws a small sample of
blood from the jugular vein of the cow
it is the blood
that will tell the tail
in the laboratory the blood serum that
clear liquid at the top of the tube
is drawn off the dark red mass at the
bottom of the tube is the clotted blood
corpuscles
if the cow is infected this clear liquid
will contain a substance called
agglutinin
[Music]
four amounts of serum are placed in the
four squares of the glass plate
[Music]
each of these rows represents a
different cow
[Music]
now the antigen
a blue liquid containing thousands of
the germs that cause the disease
one drop of antigen is added to the
squares on the plate
[Music]
now
watch what happens
[Music]
the two rows to the left remain
unchanged
but keep your eye on that third row
there
the enemy is unmasked
watch him cluster in tight little knots
that blood serum is from a cow heavily
infected with brucellosis
this test is run on every cow in the
wilson herd
and here in the laboratory is the
beginning of the counter-attack against
brucella abortis
the battle of science against a killer
there are many things to worry about
when this invisible enemy strikes out of
nowhere not half as big as the point of
the finest needle ever made
yet it can wreck a family's plans
bud
he's pretty much worried about that calf
mrs wilson remembers a neighbor whose
dairy herd was wiped out by the disease
the neighbor who had to sell out leave
his home and his farm
the buildings are now dilapidated and
sagging
can this happen to the wilsons
not if tom wilson can help it
he's determined to give this disease a
good fight it can be licked can be wiped
out
[Music]
yes there's a lot of worrying going on
at the wilson place
[Music]
here is the man with the verdict
[Music]
luckily for tom wilson only three cows
are infected the heifer that lost her
calf
and two other
which too
[Music]
tom wilson's first job is to get rid of
those three animals ship them off for
slaughter
the state and federal governments will
pay him an indemnity to cover part of
the loss
this is the second diseased cow in the
wilson herd
[Music]
which one is third
number three is this heifer
right here
step number two
tom wilson has all his young calves
between the ages of four and eight
months old vaccinated
another part of the battle in the war
science is waging against brucellosis
[Music]
vaccination helps the animal build up a
resistance against the disease
and it gives cattle owners some
assurance of clean healthy productive
herds
this vaccine called strain 19 is worth
millions of dollars to cattlemen
throughout the nation
here in the laboratory of the bureau of
animal industry at beltsville maryland
thousands of doses of strain 19 vaccine
are prepared every year and shipped to
all parts of the country
[Music]
like all vaccines this one is made from
the germ itself brucella abortis which
is grown in cultures like these
it is much too weak to hurt the
vaccinated animal but it is strong
enough to build up the animal's
resistance there's a liberal margin of
safety
[Music]
when the last calf is vaccinated
and the last infected animal marked with
a bee on the left jaw is shipped away
for slaughter
the wilsons are ready for the third step
cleaning up the premises
[Music]
it's a long hard job
but it's the part that clinches the
victory against brucellosis
plenty of scrubbing
plenty of disinfectant
[Music]
carting off manure piles which probably
contain billions of germs
[Music]
yes it takes the whole kitten caboodle
every man on the wilson place to wipe
out every possible spot where this
deadly germ could live
including its favorite breeding ground
the animals themselves
tom wilson will have his herd retested
again and again
until it is accredited as free of
brucellosis
[Music]
this deadly invader can be
and is being stamped out
farm by farm
county by county
state by state
[Music]
you sure is a beautiful baby
[Music]
healthy disease-free herds
are worth the battle
so
you